Despite the fact that Wilson
had just won reelection in 1916
based on a platform of keeping
the United States out of war,
by April of 1917,
the administration
had decided that Germany
had gone too far.
And in particular,
had gone too far
with the unrestricted
submarine warfare.
So this right over
here is a picture
of President Wilson on
April 2, 1917, giving a war
message to Congress
as to why the US needs
to declare war on Germany.
And April 4, Congress passes
the resolution to declare war.
And then the President
approves it on April 6.
So by early April, the United
States was at war with Germany.
Which is a good time to
start thinking about,
why did all of this happen.
Now, the things
that are typically
cited, and these
are the things that
are inflamed public opinion in
the US and that many of which
were cited by President
Woodrow Wilson.
And in this tutorial
that this is
part of on
khanacademy.org, I put
the entire text of his speech,
which I highly recommend
reading to see all of the
things the President Wilson
cited in his speech.
But just as a summary of that,
the things that tend to get
cited most often are the
unrestricted submarine warfare
on the part of Germany.
And particular cases
or the most cited
example of that is the
sinking of the Lusitania.
The Germans had stopped
doing that for a little
under two years.
But then, as we enter into
1917, they began doing it again.
And it also made the
Americans quite angry
to realize that the
Germans were trying
to incite the
Mexicans against them.
So you have the
Zimmerman telegram.
Zimmerman telegram
is also a reason
that the Wilson administration,
and why people in general,
were fairly angry about things.
Now, on top of that,
there were atrocities
committed by the
Germans in their march
through Belgium as
they were trying
to execute on the
Schlieffen Plan.
So Belgian atrocities.
And these were earlier in the
war in 1914, which immediately
made many Americans not
like what's going on.
Belgian atrocities.
And to put on top
of that, the British
were able to leverage the
Belgian atrocities to fairly,
to execute a fairly effective
propaganda campaign in America.
Now on top of that--
and this is something
that Wilson speaks very
strongly about in his speech--
is the notion of
fighting for democracy.
And what you have here, in the
First World War, the Central
Powers.
You're talking about
the German Empire,
you're talking about
the Austro-Hungarians.
These are monarchies.
These are emperors who
are controlling it.
And even though the
UK, the United Kingdom,
was nominally a kingdom,
it was really a democracy.
At least for those
who could vote.
We're not talking about
the entire British Empire.
So UK is functionally a
democracy, democratic.
And so was the Third
French Republic.
And so was France.
So there's this
argument that the US
is fighting for the
representation of people.
Now, there is a more
cynical argument
that some people have made.
And I think it's reasonable
to give that to due time.
And one of the
cynical arguments,
or more cynical
arguments, is that the US
had close financial and
trade ties to Britain,
not to mention cultural ties.
Financial ties to the British.
On top of that, you had very
successful British propaganda.
One, talking about the
atrocities in Belgium,
which did actually happen.
But the British
were able to exploit
this as a propaganda machine.
Successful propaganda.
But they also spread rumors
that after the sinking
of the Lusitania
that the Germans
had their school
children celebrating.
And these were all
made up propaganda.
And then, more
cynical view of why
the US entered the
war-- and this is true
of probably most
wars-- is that there
was a lot of lobbying on
the part of war profiteers.
In fact, in "Little Orphan
Annie," Daddy Warbucks,
the name, the reason why
his last name is Warbucks
is because he made his
fortune as a war profiteer
during World War I.
And war profiteers,
these are people who might be
selling arms to the Allies.
Or who might sell arms
to the US government
if the US were to get into
a war that might somehow
supply the troops.
And it includes, potentially,
folks on Wall Street.
There were significant
lending to the Allies,
and mainly the Allies,
not the Central Power.
And so the view is
if the Allies win,
those loans are going
to be made good.
And I had the entire
text of the speech
from Senator George Norris
who was one of five senators,
or sorry, one of six senators
to vote against the resolution
to go to war.
There were 50 representatives
who also voted against it.
This is a little excerpt
but also in this tutorial,
I have the full
text of his speech.
And I highly, highly, highly
recommend reading that
along with Wilson's text of his
speech to Congress in his war
message.
But I'll just read this part
because it does, I think,
point out that the US,
from the beginning,
did have biases that
were more pro-British.
And so this is
part of his speech.
"The reason given
by the President
in asking Congress to
declare war against Germany
is that the German government
has declared certain war zones,
within which by the
use of submarines,
she sinks, without
notice, American ships
and destroys American lives.
The first war zone was
declared by Great Britain.
She gave us and the
world notice of it
on the 4th day of November 1914.
The zone became effective
November 5, 1914.
This zone, so declared
by Great Britain,
covered the whole
of the North Sea.
The first German war
zone was declared
on the 4th day of
February, 1915,
just three months after the
British war zone was declared.
Germany gave 15 days
notice of the establishment
of her zone, which
became effective
on the 18th day
of February, 1915.
The German war zone
cover the English Channel
and the high seawaters
around the British Isles.
It is unnecessary
to cite authority
to show that both of these
orders declaring military zones
were illegal and contrary
to international law.
It is sufficient to say that
our government has officially
declared both of
them to be illegal
and has officially protested
against both of them.
The only difference is
that, in the case of Germany
we have persisted
in our protest,
while in the case of
England, we have submitted."
And I encourage you,
once again, to read
the text of both Wilson's speech
and Senator Norris' speech
and come up to your,
with your own decisions.
And it might be a
little bit of both.